the video made headlines around the
country and the flight delays lasted for
hours now we're learning more about the
incident yesterday at read international
thanks for joining us i'm vanessa murphy
and i'm brian loftis things are back to
normal at the airport tonight but the
scene yesterday really was chaotic 24
hours later there are still many
questions to be answered 8 news now
reporter victoria saha joins us live
from the airport with new information
from tsa
[Applause]
[Music]
brian and vanessa those reports of shots
fired had people running all around the
airport some run outside some even
running through tsa and today we're
finding out more information about the
chaos that unfolded right here at the
airport yesterday
passengers elbow to elbow as they wait
the long lines to get through tsa
screening after the airport was deemed
safe from any threat the passengers in
line were going through screening for
the first time that day and many had to
be re-screened i reached out to tsa
spokesperson lori dankers tells me when
a loud noise caused panic passengers
scrambled to find safety and tsa allowed
them to rush through the detectors and
wait near the gates that loud noise
happened around 4 30 sunday morning
causing a panic then around 6 30 k-9
officers and metro sweep the area of
terminal 1 allowing for tsa operations
to resume then at 9 30 those passengers
who are waiting in line for hours were
all screened the huge delay in screening
happened because passengers who had
already gone through tsa once and were
waiting to board their flight had to be
re-screened t-s-a says they brought in
off-duty employees to help with the
lines
as for the person responsible but for
all this panic police say 33-year-old
stephon hutchinson was arrested he's
being charged with burglary of a
business we're still trying to get some
more information about what exactly he
did that caused all of this reporting
from read international victoria saha
live local now
the spokesperson for tsa says the team
did everything right in this situation
when it comes to an active shooter which
is run hide or fight they wanted
everyone to find a safe place airport
leaders plan to go over the situation
and see if they need to make any
improvements